-Good evening,
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night," we hope
you're doing well tonight.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
"The New York Times" has
published additional audio
of House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy
and the aftermath
of the Capitol attack.
All right, how do we have this
much audio of Kevin McCarthy?
Pretty soon, we're gonna be able
to put out an E.P..
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said yesterday
that his administration
is making progress on reducing
the national debt.
Oh, good, that was
definitely the thing I was
most worried about.
[ Laughter ]
What about abortion,
the pandemic, climate change?
The Democrats are like the
people who offer
to bring the most boring
thing to a party.
"Good news, everyone, the
napkins are here!"
[ Laughter ]
"The soiree can begin!"
President Biden warned yesterday
that the leaked opinion
that indicated the Supreme Court
is prepared to overturn
Roe v. Wade could threaten
other freedoms and said,
"What happens if you have states
change the laws
saying that children who are
LGBTQ can't be in classrooms
with other children?"
Said Republicans,
"Oh, hey, that's good.
That's good."
[ Laughter ]
"What else you got?"
Florida Congressman Matt Gaetz
tweeted yesterday...
Which is pretty bold coming
from a guy
who does all his dating
on Venmo.
[ Laughter ]
Several journalists across
multiple news outlets
have reportedly tested positive
for the coronavirus
after attending last weekend's
White House Correspondents'
Dinner.
So all those articles about how
we're back to normal
are gonna be a week late.
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump Jr. reportedly
met on Tuesday
with the House Committee
investigating
the Capitol attack remotely
for more than three hours.
Three hours doesn't seem
very long,
but because it's Don Jr.,
it still came out
to like eight hours' worth
of testimony.
-The media runs right away.
It's Russian disinformation.
There's literally zero evidence
that it's Russian dis--
[ Laughter ]
-President Biden mistakenly said
at a White House event this week
that there's never been
a senator from Delaware.
While the GOP is trying
to convince us there's
never been a congressman
from North Carolina.
[ Laughter ]
Sunday is Mother's Day,
which means today is
"I got plenty of time
to get a card."
Tomorrow is
"I should get a card."
Saturday is
"What about an e-card?"
And Sunday is "I'm screwed."
[ Laughter ]
Residents of Nantucket voted
yesterday to allow
everyone to go topless
on its beaches,
bringing them one step closer
to finally living up
to their limericks.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
An -- Yes, sometimes it takes
a minute for the limerick jokes
to land.
[ Laughter ]
We'll be patient.
An otter was recently spotted
swimming in the Detroit River
for the first time
in over 100 years.
But I'm willing to bet
that it's a different otter.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the FDA is looking
at a new proposed rule
to ban menthol cigarettes.
Here to talk about it is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment called
"Is This Racist?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The FDA is going to ban
menthol cigarettes,
and that's ra-- well...
I mean, it is...
[ Laughter ]
Okay. No, wait.
[ Stammers ] I mean,
it feels ra--
[ Laughter ]
But is it, like,
all-the-way racist?
I -- Okay, okay, okay.
You gotta look at the -- uh...
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ] Yeah,
'cause if I say that,
then that means
the other thing, so,
dicey, dicey, dicey.
Uh...Okay. Wait.
I got it.
It is racist, because
the other cigarettes
are, well -- that's different.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Wait.
Okay.
Yeah, okay, wait, no.
Not racist, final answer.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!
-Wait! No, I mean,
maybe it is a little --
-We got a great show
for you tonight.